ladies and gentlemen if you haven't
already heard Donald Trump is going uh
what does Curtis say postal on Ron
DeSantis
all right I'm gonna read for you the the
statement from Donald Trump he writes
News Corp which is Fox The Wall Street
Journal and the no longer great New York
Post bring back coal is all in for
governor Ron Des sanctimonious an
average Republican governor with great
public relations who didn't have to
close up his state but did unlike other
Republican Governors whose overall
numbers for a republican were just
average middle of the pack including
coven and who has the ADV advantage of
sunshine where people from badly run
States up north would go no matter who
the governor was just like I did
Ron came to me in Desperate shape in
2017. he was politically dead losing in
a landslide to a very good agriculture
commissioner Adam Putnam
who was loaded up with cash and great
poll numbers Ron had low approval bad
polls and no money but he said that if I
would endorse him he could win I didn't
know Adam so I said let's give it a shot
Ron when I endorsed him it was as though
to use a bad term a nuclear weapon went
off years later they were the exact
words that Adam Putnam used in
describing Ron's endorsement he said I
went from having it made with no
competition to immediately getting
absolutely clobbered after your
endorsement I then got run by the star
of the democratic party Andrew Gillum by
having two massive rallies of tens of
thousands of people at each one I also
fixed his campaign which had completely
Fallen apart I was all in for Ron and he
beat Gillum but after the race when
votes were being stolen by the corrupt
election process in Broward County and
Rod was going down 10 000 votes a day I
sent in the FBI and the U.S attorneys
and the ballot theft immediately ended
just prior to them running out of votes
necessary to win I stopped his election
from being stolen and now Ron D
sanctimonious is playing games the fake
news asks him if he's going to to run if
president Trump runs and he says I'm
only focused on the governor's race I'm
not looking into the future well in
terms of loyalty in class that's really
not the right answer this is just like
2015 and 16 a media assault collusion
when Fox News fought me to the end until
I won and then they couldn't have been
nicer or more supportive The Wall Street
Journal loved low energy Jeb Bush and a
succession of other people as they
rapidly disappeared from sight finally
falling in line with me after I easily
knocked knocked them out one by one we
are in exactly the same position now
they will keep coming after us Maga But
ultimately we will win put America first
and make America great again this has to
be one of the cringiest things I've ever
heard from Trump and it's sad it's very
very sad Rhonda Sanders didn't say
anything about him Trump comes out after
Ron's double digit a 20-point victory
and then is just for no reason insulting
Rhonda Santos yeah it's kind of a little
pathetic it's a sign of weakness you
know because you're you're what he's
doing is essentially spreading Division
and his comments began with covet
because that's one and again one of the
strongest talking points against Donald
Trump and where the two are the most
different Donald Trump told everyone to
lock down said we need 14 days to slow
the spread got Dr fauci to to Mark out
orders told everyone to listen to Dr
fauci launched operation warp speed told
everyone to take the vaccine when
DeSantis didn't lock down he didn't have
any mask mandates in his States and he
told people hey if you want to take the
vaccine take it but it's up to you and
your doctor to make those decisions for
yourselves that's the biggest difference
there and I think this is why Donald
Trump started by talking about kovid in
his kind of unhinged attacks against
DeSantis when it could have been a
moment of congratulations like hey
DeSantis you did great I hope other
people in the party do great as well
maybe we should work together but but we
don't have any imagine if he said
instead of insulting Ron DeSantis if he
said I remember when Ron DeSantis came
to me and said I need your support and I
said Ron you're a good guy you have
great policies I am going to be there
for you and now we see just how
successful he's become imagine if you
just said that said I was proud to stand
with Ron DeSantis and I'm proud now to
see his success I'm glad that I I threw
my weight behind him when I did because
now we're seeing a true star that would
have come off as strong yeah well and I
think so many people followed Trump and
they were hoping to see more candid
candidates like Rhonda santis pave way
and do the same bold outspoken stuff
that Trump did and then so when you have
him he actually knocks them down
from somebody who loves Trump I don't
like to see that you want it as many
trumps you want a whole movement I mean
if you're a part of that Maga movement
you want more and more of that and you
don't want just Trump exactly what
happened is when you're gone Trump you
want to you know bring up a whole
another generation of politicians that
are going to be bold that aren't going
to be you know kissing media but and so
you get someone like that and Rhonda
Santas and then he
yeah yeah but Trump is up there when it
comes to age and there's a there's an
opportunity there to to help people to
build and grow but but that's not what
we have here so let me let me piss
everybody off so we don't need another
80 year old President we don't okay now
I supported Trump now when I I didn't
understand Trump 2015 but when I walked
into the voting booth there were two
boxes it was Hillary Clinton and not
Hillary Clinton I checked the one that
said not Hillary Clinton uh and we wound
up with Donald Trump now again I he
converted me he brought me over I I
could see through the the stuff I could
see through the if you will a comedic
timing that he has which is really
pretty damn good uh but he was
anti-establishment I think a lot of
people love that but they love that
aspect about him he wasn't one of those
bought and paid for 50-year politicians
as we as we've become used to and people
will make the argument they'll say well
without Trump there would be no DeSantis
and maybe that's true maybe that's true
without Trump maybe there's no Lauren
Bowman maybe there's no Margaret Taylor
I should be like yes look at all these
people I've brought up versus right when
they succeed I mean you that's trying to
bring them different yeah it's like
obviously he's threatened by him which
is stupid he even said he's starting to
look like and everybody says well it's
45d 18d chess right Trump knows all he
walks on water right he's the Savior
he's the Messiah I get it everybody's
knee-deep in this cult did you know that
personality Donald Trump the name it
means Herald of the world ruler no so
Donald but it sounds like you should
Donald is uh I'm so I'm I'm being a
little um editorial with it but Trump
means like the trumping sound the
Declaration right and Donald means World
ruler it and listen I I was sitting with
Donald Trump Jr the night I CJ and I
were the night I decided I was going to
run for governor oh and I sing songs
about Trump
rally I love him we've been around I
mean obviously the point is we've put
our support well the point is is what
I'm scared of is he actually it's okay
it works when you do it to Ted Cruz I
mean we love Ted Cruz but you know he's
not likable you know
it works it works we all get a kick out
of it but when you go after somebody
that's done so much for America
it's like it's gonna rub your fan base
the wrong way and the other day I guess
it was yesterday on Truth Trump said now
that the election in Florida is over
everything went quite well shouldn't be
said that in 2020 I got 1.1 million more
votes in Florida than Ron D got this
year 5.7 million to 4.6 million just
asking so I tweeted it this morning I
mulled over it for 24 hours and I said
dumb
uh Trump's ego getting in the way again
and there's literally no justifying a
move like this now psychologically I I
agree with you Tim I don't think there's
any way you look at this it becomes
cringy people that want to see two
Heroes come together and say let's be a
Powerhouse but but remember that Meme
that it was the Babylon B they wrote an
article it said ingenious move Trump
supports impeachment forcing Democrats
to oppose you remember that Babylon B
article yeah and then they just wrote
basically you know Democrats now had no
choice you see this is my favorite
conspiracy theory here Donald Trump
knows no matter what he does they will
they will take the opposite side of it
so Trump starts going after DeSantis so
all the never trumpers all of the
moderates all and many Democrats are
going to be alike screw you Trump I like
DeSantis yeah that's wild [ __ ] but I can
see it Trump is I'm I'm kidding honestly
I think Trump is got an ego and he's mad
that DeSantis is doing so well because
he wants to run but uh we can just
imagine that Trump is actually so Noble
he's willing to sacrifice his own image
gotta wish to force him
listen we look we talked to Trump
Tuesday night right so we're sitting
there we did our panel discussion on the
blaze Sarah Gonzalez glidbeck we're all
sitting there Ed we had Trump for 15 20
minutes right in in three times Glenn
asked him he said hey you know you when
you announce on the 15th that you're
going to run for president Trump ignored
the question until the third time
finally quite honestly you're gonna love
what I gotta say You're Gonna Love it
you're gonna appreciate what I'm gonna
say you're gonna love it and it's like
your assumption is yeah he's going to
announce he's running for president I
can't in a million years imagine he's
going to say I'm going to throw all of
my power and my weight behind Iran
DeSantis who look I have no doubt I have
no question I mean even I'm not going to
quote Roger Stone but even Roger Stone
told me one time he's like I don't trust
Rhonda Santas he's to establishment
maybe he is to establishment but I'll
tell you the guy's done a hell of a job
but when When Donald Trump criticized uh
Ted Cruz there's legitimate things to
criticize Cruz on what is he criticizing
Ron DeSantis on I'm not seeing it why
hasn't he made a strong legitimate
argument about what exactly Ron DeSantis
has done he hasn't been doing it he
actually said what he did he was upset
that he didn't come out right saying he
wasn't going to run for president yeah
yeah and again that's right that's
that's belligerent insane kind of
thinking that that's absolutely based on
the ego and what is it doing it's it's
creating division amongst a party that
that again is fighting within the party
and and even that one side the the
anti-establishment faction which I think
is represented by Trump and DeSantis is
fighting within that party so so it's a
civil war within a civil war of this
political party which is spreading more
Division and of course making sure that
the that the populist branch of the
party will never get get any significant
strength they're they're the neocons are
happy when the neocons that are watching
this right now they're happy they're
cheering this on they're calling this in
the press the GOP Civil War and I'm like
yo the Civil War's in 2015. and Donald
Trump won and then was at war or he he
won he wins this fight in the primary
but then he's in this long battle with
the GOP establishment that civil War's
been going on if they're now claiming
this is a civil war they're admitting
Trump won that Maga won the Republican
party that's it
well and it did well never mind wouldn't
it be nice I mean in a perfect world in
my perfect world I could see Trump and a
DeSantis that come along and say you
know what we recognize the Democrats and
the Republicans are the flip side of the
same big government coin they're all
corrupt we've been screwed by the
two-party system system they basically
ruined a constitutional republic let's
start a whole other party
um
Libertarians but but how can they start
a party when they keep fighting each
other that's the problem my perfect
world but they're not going to do it but
but there was even a couple rights that
were talking about I'm an interrupter my
bad sorry no no no
one really quick question I just want to
make one quick Point here there was a
couple right-wing pundits that were
making the call that DeSantis and Donald
Trump should run together and this was
going to be a dream ticket that could
definitely Dominate and beat the
Democrats and now they're that's that's
not gonna happen sorry go ahead no I I
listen I got kids I always talk over
them I'm like listen to me sorry but I
was like you're saying how you know it
could be they're they're causing
everybody to look at them like this
fighting this infighting all the plan
and then all of a sudden they come out
holding hands it's the American dream
this could look a lot of people want to
believe that Trump's always playing
fourth dimensional chess like that
implies it's multi-layered and he's
traveling through time or something but
uh whether it's on purpose or not this
is owning the news cycle and that means
Democrats are never going to get a a
minute of of of time to talk so they've
got no stars that Beto and Abrams are
their stars and they just keep losing
they're famous for losing Beto's now
lost what he heard three in less than
four years
in less than four years I want somebody
I was going to do it but I didn't have
time I want somebody to come out with a
meme that shows little African kids
wearing Beto shirts you know from after
the election and I want them to see like
these kids growing they've got a kid
that's Beto for Senate Beto for
president Beto for uh governor and just
they just keep growing in these shirts
uh and then you have a meme where
there's an outlet store called discount
clothing and it's all about no shirts
all the different kinds of beta percent
a bit over Governor hey I hope I hope he
runs again because
he'll probably run in corn is a piece of
trash but the uh to your point Tim I
agree with you I think that uh you got
Trump who I mean I'd love to have the
kind of power where you could sit on the
toilet in the West Wing at 3 30 in the
morning freshly spray painted orange and
and just hair hasn't moved in four days
and just hit tweet you know and just say
Cafe and it controls the news cycle for
36. right yeah I mean that's laser
pointer to cats kind of power uh and he
could do that he knows he can do that
and he's not even on Twitter he's doing
his own truth well let's think about
this if Trump really was a smart guy
right and I'm not I'm saying you know I
think Trump is a smart guy but if he was
like a tactful Mastermind what if he
really was thinking I he he didn't like
Luke pointed out he didn't actually
attack DeSantis for anything he's
attacking him but not really criticizing
him on anything right what's the purpose
of that we're talking about it it's
making it look like Trump is whining and
doesn't like DeSantis it's giving to
Santa's the story now is he's like you
just said it's a big win but I was
bigger he's making the Press continually
report to Santa's won by by Massive
numbers without actually attacking the
scientists it's a good point but what if
Trump is thinking they will hate me no
matter what I do if I run but the Santa
says my proxy if I hate him he wins and
then gives me favors good point well
Trump's been I mean that's one theory
that that needs to be backed by some
evidence
yeah yeah but but Trump has been
attacking the Santos for a very long
time he's been making small Jabs against
him throughout the last few months and
years that that are becoming pretty
evident that there is a kind of ego
battle here I don't think it's for the
chess who in the world knows but at the
end of the day I think we should be
skeptical of DeSantis I think we should
be skeptical of Donald Trump a bit but
right now DeSantis is really doing a lot
by not saying anything and by by not
reacting by not playing into the ego by
not counter-attacking a lot of people
are like wow uh he's handling this in in
a in a way better way than the former
president of the United States you know
what I love uh I wake up after the
midterm and I see these posts where
where they're like what happened last
night this is Trump's fault and all that
stuff and I'm like I don't know what's
going on like did the Republicans lost
and I look and it's like New York Times
projects 20 200 224 seats for the
Republicans and it's a toss-up it might
go to 51 in the Senate maybe not and
then I'm like okay so these are this
okay so they won wait hold on these
leftists are cheering Colbert is
gloating Jimmy Kimmel is laughing
they're posting pictures of like a
spattering of ketchup on the floor and
they're like yo we won and I'm like
Hillary Clinton she goes it turns out
women like their rights and they vote
and I'm like lady you lost like I don't
understand this means Nancy Pelosi's
done she's out this is like the most
powerful Democrat has just lost and now
she's done and they're cheering for this
what do you call someone who celebrates
having lost
a crazy person a loser at minimum but I
don't understand I know you know we had
Milo on the other day and he mentioned
it's because the Republicans wanted
revenge and I was like oh gee I guess
I'll have to settle for winning I get it
you want revenge no I totally understand
a blowout Landslide would feel great
sorry guys you'll have to accept just
having one you just have to one yeah
just one but it's also important to note
here that Ron DeSantis did endorse
candidates in this election that didn't
win so he doesn't also have a perfect
record as well Donald Trump also
endorsed candidates didn't win but
Donald Trump's getting a lot of the
criticism and a lot of fact from Flack
from it some people say it's deserved
some people say it's not I I think what
happened in Pennsylvania with Oz is the
criticism there is absolutely deserved
uh I think what what happened in Georgia
he criticized the candidate there that
that one so again it's a mixed bag of
what's going on here but when we look at
the midterms I mean this is the best
midterm for Democrats since then since
1986. for Democrats uh for Democrats yes
and Biden uh Biden had a better midterm
than Clinton and Obama this is one of
the best performing midterms for
incoming political party in the last 20
years so so there's one reason for it I
I think there's a lot of reasons there's
one reason it's not because of policy
it's not it's because of mail-in ballots
and redistricting thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time